[Music]
anyway facebook going down i love how
blown out of proportion
this got yeah but like it also was
because of the whistleblower
yes and the pandora papers too yeah like
happening in the same day did you dig
into the pandora papers i didn't yeah a
little bit
uh what's who has money
uh i mean it's basically just about how
it's like the it kind of it's like the
biggest expose on
uh how rich people and politicians hide
money offshore that there's ever been
right
nice where do they put it although is it
real is it related to the panama papers
because i believe that was the same
thing
and that was like 10 years ago i think
so i don't know
how these ones how these newer ones are
different but basically it's 2.7
terabytes of documents damn i'm gonna go
through it all leaked from
like a law firm i believe that
helps people hide money offshore oh sick
so
is this is this just like a torrent we
can get somewhere
i wanna read it you wanna read the whole
thing i'll go through the whole thing
i'm gonna go see it's like it's some
absurd number it's like one point eight
million people yeah i'm gonna read it
all right i'm gonna i'm 2.7 terabytes of
just
text imagine that how much how much
storage is in a like a human brain no
we're cl i mean mine
i mean we're talking a couple megabytes
kilobytes i can't even say saturation
right
situation human brain storage capacity
you build it up right here what is it
see
a thousand terabytes yeah yeah the human
brain easy that's what i'm saying
you're speed reading it like that guy on
tick tock yeah just
i can go
did we watch that on the podcast i don't
think so
did you see that one
just speed reading yeah he's like what
he's doing
okay it's so funny he's like the world's
fastest speed raider oh
is he actually reading it yeah i think
so can he retire i think it's an
official we gotta watch it now
you'll like this
listen i'm gonna read all the pandora
papers and tell you guys this exactly
where they hide the money
i don't know what that guy's impressions
wasn't funny but
let that go again
he can't possibly be reading anything i
don't know i don't know dude that sounds
like he was beatboxing that looks pretty
official doesn't it it does have a video
for sure yeah
like did they just present him with a
random money where's the money fast
faster
yeah they print out all the papers from
the pandora papers yeah that's you where
is it where's the money dude
[ __ ] barbados let's go
so what was the whistleblower thing so
this was not related to it going down it
went down because the dns was [ __ ] up
yeah somebody wiped some dns records so
they had to like rebuild that for a
second which isn't that hard that's why
i came back in like a couple hours yeah
but
then there's also the whistleblower
thing
which coincidentally was on the same day
is that yeah it was like similar yes i
think it's actually came in like a
did this come out like a week ago it
came out uh the night before
oh 60 minutes
oh right yeah
what they what she was basically saying
is it's pretty [ __ ] up stuff it's
nothing we don't really understand
already but
she
basically
like leaked documents that proved that
facebook
chooses profit over what's you know
like like they they ignore their moral
responsibility with the platform that
they have but it was like a little bit
more
explicit than that in terms of like
there's like a knob
that they can basically change the
amount of shocking content that people
see i didn't see that but yeah i did see
where she was like basically that knob
is like
they
after the election was over they're like
oh no we'll we'll turn it we'll make
sure and then the election finished and
they just ran that [ __ ] back up yeah
it's fine yeah um
yeah and like they have like some
internal data that confirms like teenage
girls using instagram like makes them x
percent more suicidal and yeah is uh but
what they what their own research had
determined is by making teenage girls
more suicidal and
basically
programming a
body image issue you know so
basically promoting an eating disorder
within children it makes them more
engaged on instagram yeah so yeah
that's what it is
it's completely correlated yeah now the
more
the more shocking swing is
the more uh radical it is
the more engaged people are obviously
because you're like holy [ __ ] and the
more money that they make yeah
that's what the thing is it's crazy that
they just have this
thing where it's like if you turn it all
the way up it's suicide and civil unrest
and civil war and yeah and if you turn
it down everyone's like happier and
they're still like let's keep it like
get the middle yeah i think the most
shocking part is the amount of users
they have it's like
it's like sixty percent of active users
on the internet or something okay
i don't know how they get that number
but it was some maybe it's not active
users on the internet but it was like
maybe oh no i think it's registered
users they have 60 of the world
in terms of numbers
it's like 2.8 billion users on facebook
so like the
that was like a quote from 60 minutes
like the reporter so i think he was
implying like the fact that they have
this knob and they don't really care
about
ethics and morals
like they can create you know did you
read the thing about the
um english
politicians complaining directly to
facebook no
they were basically like
dude
you're making it so that we all
like in regardless of party we all have
to take these really extreme positions
on things
just to be visible on your platform yeah
and that's not good like we don't
actually want this but it's like that's
how we have to engage people yep um i
mean that's and that's everyone there's
news sites that's
anyone that's that's an ad based revenue
model that's now what they have to do
everyone
i mean even in the podcast space it's
like who's the most controversial guest
we can get yeah like how can we yeah
who is someone who's attention yeah we
can bag on and then bring them in and
create like a you know yeah i mean we're
not doing it at the at that level but
no i mean that's what people do though
like they'll you know
there's like some wrestling [ __ ] they'll
generate a beef and bring that person in
or yeah
um
but yeah yeah totally
yeah no it is everything i mean
i just keep thinking of i was trying to
brainstorm a
like uh
an extreme version of you laugh you lose
because you know i'm like ah like let's
see some [ __ ] with consequences and like
sidemen did one where they used like the
haptic machine to like
um or the tens device like with the
leads on you to shock you
um and i was like chuckling that's a
[ __ ] great idea
yeah well so i thought like oh you laugh
you get tased yeah some kids have done
that so
you know i came up with you laugh you
get pregnant okay
and
you the tens machine i just
like ratcheted up to like pregnancy
level pain yeah um
but i'm like chuckling and then i like
bailed on it i'm like this is like
ridiculous like am i really stooping
this low
you laugh you get pregnant
come on it's kind of funny it's funny
but also what the [ __ ] like
but i'll probably do it
i mean yeah it's just it
that's all that's all social media now
you can't be on the edge no one cares
about on the edge
even people who are like annoying and
you don't get why they're popular
it's that like
a lot of those views are hate watches
yeah it's just shocking
a lot of people don't like trisha paytas
and yeah i think that contributes to her
having a career
so long yep
you